well it's great to be back that's a lie
of course it's not great adults it's
deeply darkly depressing to be back from
vacation but we did have a good vacation
we're up in New Hampshire I did quite a
lot of fishing and I did pretty good I I
posted a picture on facebook of one of
the bats that I caught it was you know
I'd say around 6 pounds I didn't I
didn't measure it but I put it up I put
the picture on Facebook for like the for
people who might care it's there so you
can go see it but it was fun did a lot
of fishing and and hung out and with the
family and so now I'm back and we'll
just dive right into it Tommy Lehren
gave her final thoughts over the weekend
where she explained that conservatives
need to stop with the whole abortion
thing we just need to quit it with the
abortion already we need to stop trying
to overturn roe v-- wade you know
because she's uncomfortable with the
fact that there's been this discussion
of overturning roe v wade now that we're
getting trumps supreme court pick so she
says that we lose on the social issues
and the best thing is to ignore them
and here's a little bit more of what she
had to say she says to use conservatives
newfound power and poll to challenge a
decision that roe v-- wade is this to
challenge a decision that according to a
new poll most American support would be
a mistake
because of course we know that something
must be good if most Americans support
it because most Americans could never be
wrong about anything in a similar way
when when most of the members of a mob
decide that it's a good idea to set a
cop-caller on file fire it would be a it
would be wrong to oppose them because
because most of them want to do it so it
must be good and it's wrong too and that
is if we equate the word wrong with the
word unpopular if those two words are
the same now then of course it would be
wrong but if unpopular and wrong are the
same well then the word wrong has no
meaning anymore and therefore the word
right has no meaning and so we just live
in a morally relativistic world which is
apparently exactly the kind of world
that tommy'll aaron conservatives
conservatives like her want to live in
but we'll get to that in a minute
she continues this president is winning
for the American people on the economy
foreign policy and tax reform these are
areas that benefit all Americans
regardless of religion or social beliefs
I would say that all Americans kind of
benefit from being granted the
opportunity to be born I would say that
you know I benefited from that Tommy
Lehren benefited from I think that Tommy
Larry would consider it a benefit that
she is born as opposed to not being born
I you know I so but that's just me she
says if we continue to focus on those
things and immigration will sail into
2020 with all three government branches
in our control yes because immigration
is just an issue with with with with
complete agree agreement everyone agrees
on that right there's a it's not
contentious at all everyone has exactly
the same view on immigration don't they
that's how we get things done for the
American people that's how we win now
obviously that's how we get things done
for the American people
Tommy Lehren is excluding unborn people
from the title of American people which
means that we are all we have all been
excluded we are all excluded at some
point in our
element she says let's go after
sanctuary cities and push for voter ID
laws we lose when we start messing with
social issues that later on she says do
we really want to fight for this
alienate Democrats oh yeah well you
wouldn't want to alienate Democrats like
let's only talk about the things that
Democrats agree on because of course
immigration is one of those things right
do we really want to fight for this
alienate Democrats moderates and
libertarians all to lose in the end
anyway
that's a risk I don't think is worth
taking this is the voice of courage that
you're hearing right here I'm saying
this as someone who would personally
choose life but also feels it's not the
government's place to dictate this isn't
a black and white issue and I would
never judge anyone in that position
let's be honest the federal government
does few things well and I believe
regulating social issues is an area
where it fails let the churches the
nonprofits and the community groups step
in not Almighty Uncle Sam now I want to
respond to this idea half-baked though
it may be and I respond only because it
is a popular idea among so-called
conservatives especially those in
Tommy's age bracket and younger this
idea of well let's put the social issues
to the side so it's a pretty common idea
that's why I think it's worth responding
to and I'm going to leave aside the most
obvious flaw with her argument well
there there a few very obviously there's
a few things we're gonna basically leave
aside because I have to choose when I'm
breaking this down and dissecting the
flaws I can't dissect all the flaws
because I'll be here for sixty two hours
I have to just choose a few so let's
leave aside the more obvious flaws like
the fact that Tommy says Tommy says the
government shouldn't regulate social
issues because the government is
incompetent and then in the next breath
she says that we should focus on
immigration taxes and foreign policy two
out of the three of those issues are
areas where Tommy wants
more government involvement she says
that Almighty Uncle Sam cannot be given
the task of defending unborn life but we
can trust it to defend life across the
globe because that's what she's talking
about with foreign policy is going in
and defending life across the globe and
we should be able to trust it to defend
the borders now I agree on that second
proposition we should be able to trust
the government to defend the proposition
I'm iffy on the first but we need the
government all over the world defending
life everywhere on the globe but the
fact remains that border hawks and
interventionists look kind of ridiculous
when they suddenly become you know
libertarians on quote social issues I
mean it's kind of hard to argue let's
put a wall on the border let's put the
military down there I mean let's just
let's just let's build forts and moats
and everything down there and let's have
the government all over the place but at
the same time the government has no
business whatsoever defending babies no
business we can't get them anywhere near
that I just I that's tip it's difficult
to square those two views in my opinion
and speaking of social issues I do have
a quick question what the heck is a
social issue I mean people like Tommy
what they'll do is they'll use the term
social issue as a way of kind of shoving
to the side things like abortions just a
way of sort of shooing it away it's just
a social issue well what does that mean
what's a social issue I can only assume
that a social issue is an issue that
affects society a social issue is a
societal issue it is social right
well on what basis can mean if abortion
is a social issue that is an immigration
a social issue on what basis can
abortion be called a social issue but
something like immigration or taxes are
not social issues I mean these are all
issues that affect society right they
are social issues I would submit in fact
that social issues are the only issues
that government should be worried about
so to say that social issues are the
only issues that government should not
be concerned with is nonsensical they
are precisely the issues that government
should be concerned with because if
something is not a social issue then
that must mean that it is a private and
personal issue now I know that when
people say social issue what they really
mean to say is those are private and
personal but then maybe you should say
that because you're using language that
makes no sense
it is my position that abortion is in
fact a social issue in that it affects
society it affects everybody
so obviously the government should be
involved in it if you're saying the
government shouldn't be involved in it
because it doesn't affect everybody and
it's personal then it's not a social
issue you see well let's put all that to
the sub-point to the side I have I have
three main points of contention with
Tommy on this issue him and with so many
other people who make us the same kind
of case number one Tommy says that we
need to get back to focusing on the
economy
you know because abortion is it just
isn't an issue that people care about
that much and
again is a common sentiment among a
certain set of conservative especially
the the soap that the self-appointed
conservative spokespeople this is a this
is a a point that you hear a lot and
every time it's articulated the person
articulating it seems to think that
they're the first person to ever say
this they they they seem to think like
Tommy is saying is she seems to think
that she has she has said something new
and insightful like you know what you
know actually I think we should put
social with social issues to the side
and just focus on taxes instead she
doesn't seem to realize that Republicans
have been saying this for the last 50
years
this has been standard operating
procedure for Republicans in the
mainstream for 50 years
Republicans have been ignoring social
issues you've already gotten what you
want this is what they've already been
doing
and well let's look at the results
publicans have basically ignored issues
like abortion
um
and what has been the result has it
resulted in a culture dominated by
conservative ideas
yeah we've won some elections we
Republicans won in 2016
great fantastic but the culture
this decision to put socialist issues to
the side and to basically punt on them
and to say well the Liberals can have
those they're not important has that
worked out or has it created a culture
that is completely utterly dominated by
leftist ideas and has it in fact created
entire generations
that are that are almost entirely owned
by these ideas
I think it's been in the ladder
so what it suggested that Republicans
are focusing too much on abortion I
could only say that that's wrong because
Republicans focus hardly at all on
abortion so I really have no idea what
you're talking about
I mean really what do you this constant
to plenty oh let's stop talking about
abortion whoo
let me ask you this seriously can you
name for me one single Republican
politician on the national stage who
talks about abortion a lot just one give
me one of all the Republican politicians
that have been on the national stage or
are on the national stage right can you
name one for me who you would say
focuses really intensely and
consistently on this issue
I mean guys like Cruz Rubio Mike Lee
yeah they're pro-life there when the
issue comes up they will say relatively
forceful things about it but those guys
don't two of those guys were campaigning
for president in 2016
they weren't campaigning on abortion
they weren't bringing it up left and
right they rarely brought it up again
when it came up at a debate or something
and it was talked about for two and a
half minutes they said the right things
about it which is great night and I do
believe that those guys are are
legitimately pro-life but but my point
is if those guys are the guys that you
would point to and say well they're the
most focused on abortion well that tell
you tells you something because they're
hardly focused on
they were much more likely to talk about
immigration foreign policy taxes so on
and so forth no Republican politician
goes out of his way to talk about
abortion so who exactly is focused on
this issue
if you're noticing that well Republican
politicians don't talk about it you know
in the mainstream Republicans of the
mainstream don't talk about but it seems
like this issue comes up a lot
well well who is bringing it up
whose focused on
well the grassroots the people regular
Americans they're the ones who are
focused on
so when you say that we shouldn't focus
on abortion because no one cares about
it what you're really saying is the
people shouldn't focus on abortion
because the people don't care about it
but the fact that they are focused on it
seems to indicate that they do care
about it you see
and it kind of makes sense because
here's the reality issues like abortion
the so called social issues they are the
issues that drive and motivate people
far more than taxes and foreign policy
Republicans have been trying to win the
culture through taxes and foreign policy
immigration for decades and they failed
miserably
that's because people don't actually
care that much about something like
taxes did you know that people actually
don't care about taxes that much
and if people should care about taxes a
lot more than they do but the fact is is
very clear that people do not care about
it that much because if they did if
taxes were really a primary issue for
most Americans then there would have
been a full-scale violent revolution
years ago our founding fathers revolted
they had a revolution spurred at least
significantly by by taxation by things
like taxes on tea well we are getting
absolutely fleeced by taxes ours you
know the taxation that we suffer under
right now is is is is astronomically
higher is so much worse than what the
founding fathers dealt with
okay they wouldn't even tolerate a tax
on tea we have taxes on tea and we also
have taxes on literally everything else
everything you buy everything you do in
some way is taxed
and even if you're just driving down the
road you could still be pulled over and
given a you know a speeding ticket which
is really just being handed out for no
other reason than as a secondary form of
Taxation for your local town so you're
just getting you're getting you're
getting taxed at your home you're
getting taxed at the grocery store
you're getting taxed on the way to the
grocery store you're getting taxed
everywhere if people actually cared
about this if this was actually an issue
that people cared about as much as Tommy
claims they care about it then there
would be riots in the street over but as
it had over it but as it happens most
people don't care they just try to pay
their taxes or they let their taxes be
paid for them rather through the
withholding system and they just sit
back and they complain about it
sometimes but most of the time they're
just not thinking about it that's the
reality
people say they care about it if you and
if you if you were to give them a survey
and ask them what are the things you
care about well they may list taxes as
one of those things but but you know
actions speak louder than words look at
how people behave how they vote
um how they operate it's pretty clear
that people don't care that much about
that they say they do but they don't
foreign policy I mean give me a break
but you you really think the average
American is sitting around worried about
foreign policy get a hundred Americans
into a room I'd be surprised if you
could sign even five of them who could
tell you their own views on foreign
policy I mean could give you more than
like two sentences on their views on
foreign policy foreign policy I mean you
really think that millions of Americans
are streaming to the polls around
election time with foreign policy as the
thing at the top of their mind
no even something like immigration now
people do care about immigration and by
the way I'm not arguing that we
shouldn't care about these things we
should care about them I'm just saying
that people don't really that much
something like immigration people do
care about immigration but
but well I put it this way the March for
Life every year annually for decades the
march for life can draw three four five
hundred thousand people okay
the March for Life can easily draw half
a million people or more every year in
the middle of winter when it's 27
degrees outside and you're and you're
standing in them you're standing in the
in the sleet or the snow or the wind for
hours and it can still draw hundreds of
thousands of people every year and this
is without any promotion for the
mainstream media ignores it even even
Fox News basically ignores it this is
not with you know guys like Rush
Limbaugh getting up there and promoting
it and driving big sean hannity driving
people out to it this is with all those
guys basically ignoring it it's entirely
grassroots and it gets half a million
people every year
now I'd be surprised if you even if you
got FoxNews on the case if you got Rush
Limbaugh on the case if you got Sean
Hannity on the case you got everybody on
the case promoting a march to to protect
our borders a march in favor of of
abstractor immigration law I'd be
surprised if you got 10,000 people to it
let me tell you something you aren't
getting 100,000 you're not getting
anywhere close to that and you know
no it's abortion that draws that kind of
attention
you
and why is that well let's go to point
number two it makes sense
that people are so focused on this you
know and that's because pro-lifers are
either right or wrong about abortion
right I mean it's I'm a pro-lifer you
know what my position is on the subject
I'm either right or I'm wrong I can't be
right and wrong I mean I it's like I've
taken a very absolute position
so judges I just used myself okay if I
am right
then actual human beings are being
killed by the thousands every day
systematically and legally in America
and sixty million actual human beings
have been slaughtered systematically
legally in buildings that are set up
specifically for the purpose in America
over the last over the last few decades
so if I'm right if pro-lifers are right
then abortion is not just a Holocaust
but it is by far the worst Holocaust
that the world has ever seen
the numbers tell the whole story if
pro-lifers are right about abortion the
abortion is not just bad it is the worst
thing in the world hands down and second
place is not even close
so we're either wrong over right
either this is the mass slaughter of
actual human persons or it isn't
and if it is then it's the most
important issue in the world what could
possibly be more important
and that's why that's why this issue
generates so much attention that's why
people care about it
it's a matter of life and death it is
literally a matter of life and death
ooh that gets it gets it cuts through
everything and it gets right down to the
heart of the matter it gets right down
to the heart of what you believe about
life
it gets down to your priorities your
your basic fundamental philosophy of
life and that's how you motivate people
that's how you really get their
attention that's how you can get five
hundred thousand people to show up in DC
and march through the snow okay
that's how you can do it is with an
issue of life and death is when you can
it's when it's a it's a moral issue it's
an ethical issue it is a it is that
you're saying this is a in atrocity that
is happening around us it must come to
an end
that's how you get people motivated not
by saying well the tax rate is this but
it should really be this
now that's important but people aren't
gonna most people are gonna say okay
yeah I mean sure I agree with you that
be fine but we can grab them by the
collar and say people our children are
dying look around you we have to do
something about this well when you say
that to someone then they have to make a
choice they have to they can they can
agree with you they can say oh my gosh
you're right I mean I've got a this has
to be a major focus of my life now to
put an end to this I can't I can't
continue along while this is happening
and pretend it's not happening I mean
this is so important so they could
respond to you that way
or they could recoil they could go they
could flee to the other extreme and they
could say all those aren't people and if
they aren't you know if the unborn
humans are not people if they're not
human at all if they're just essentially
cancerous lumps you know lifeless
cancerous lumps then then the pro-life
position is I guess it really is
oppressive right because in that case
women are really trying to undergo a
medical procedure to have this lifeless
mass extracted from them and we're
trying to convince them not that we're
even where we we even want them to be
legally prevented from undergoing it and
so it's it's oppressive we're trying to
oppress them and so you could respond
that way and go to the other students
say oh you're oppressing but it makes no
sense to go to the middle and I know
that there are a lot of people who try
to find the middle but the point I'm
making is that there is no middle ground
these are cowards who are trying to find
a middle ground where it doesn't exist
if we are right about this then this is
the most important thing in the world
and everybody should be focused if we're
wrong then we are oppressive bullies and
you should be you should be viciously
opposed to us
but what you can't do is just kind of
like float in the middle and say well
you know maybe either way
it takes a certain
intellectual effort you know to stay in
that middle area I don't mean
intellectual effort like in a good way
I mean you really have to try to block
out of your mind the reality of the
issue you've got to put on the blinders
so that you can stay firmly in the
middle
but the issue itself naturally
provokes a strong reaction one way or
another
because it gets down to the core of a
person what do you believe about life
and and and the real question that
pro-lifers are posing to people is do
you believe that life is sacred
because that the the sacredness of life
that's the kind of thing that motivates
someone no people are willing to die
to defend the sacredness of life that's
how much they believe in it
immigration is a really important issue
very few people would die to defend
their position on immigration policy
sacredness of life about defending human
life
that is being directly systematically
slaughtered that's the kind of thing
people are they will give their life to
that
third thing
you cannot be
pro-abortion conservatives
because to be pro-abortion is to reject
its it's to do two things okay if you're
if you're pro-abortion then necessarily
and that is when I say pro-abortion
meaning you are in favor of abortion
being legal and so Tommy is Pro borsch
and what I'm saying about commie she you
know she's I'm sure she's a nice person
she's not by any means conservative in
the slightest she is a liberal she's she
is a full-on leftist extreme leftist she
has taken an extreme liberal view
and in so doing she has accepted and all
the call conservatives who are in her
camp they they have all accepted two
propositions necessarily one they have
accepted the proposition that human life
is not has no inherent dignity
okay it has no intrinsic innate inherent
me all these words are sending it has no
intrinsic dignity
because in order for something to have
something in order for you know a thing
an entity to possess a certain quality
intrinsically it means that it must
possess that quality all along from the
first moment that it is an entity from
the first moment that it exists
physically as a physical being in the
physical world it must possess this
quality if it does not then it does not
possess then it does not possess that
quality intrinsically
now you could have a entity that comes
into being and then over time acquires
certain qualities but all of those
qualities that it acquires over time it
cannot be said to possess intrinsically
and so if it should be legal to kill
unborn humans
then what you're clearly saying is that
unborn humans do not have dignity they
do not have they do not have the full
human dignity and Worth and value that
you and I have but if they don't have it
in the womb
that means that we didn't have it in the
womb which means that we have not always
had that value Worth and dignity which
means that we don't possess it
intrinsically it's not a part of our
human nature it's something that
somewhere along the line you acquire
so if you accept the pro-abortion
position then you reject the intrinsic
value earth and dignity of human life
which is a
an incredible extreme position
and also deranged demented
and in st. my opinion the second
proposition that you must accept in
order to be pro-abortion is that moral
truth is not objective
and this especially is the case for
people like Tommy people that are in the
middle who say well I'm personally
opposed to it but you know it's people
got to make their own decision so what
you're saying is you know it's it's
wrong for me I consider it wrong but
it's not necessarily wrong for her
and so what you're saying is that this
moral truth is not objective it's just
kind of up to the individual to decide
but if any moral truth is not objective
especially a moral truth dealing with
life and death if that is not objective
then it must mean that moral truth
itself is not objective that all moral
truths are not objective
if the moral truth of you know whether
or not it's okay to kill a human being
if that is not an objective matter
then what kind then which moral truth
could be objective if that doesn't
qualify
so in order to be pro-abortion you have
to be a moral relativist and you have to
be a materialist
just to say that there's no value in
human life that were just kind of we're
all just material right
but materialism and moral relativism
those are the two foundational pillars
of modern leftism that that's their
whole point that's everything they are
materialists and they are moral
relativist that's everything they
believe Springs from that fountain from
that toxic ugly algae filled fountain
that smelly sewage fountain that's
everything Springs from that from
materialism and moral relativism so if
you've agreed with them on those two
points that you've agreed with them on
everything your disagreements are
irrelevant they're just they're they're
a frivolous you've given them everything
you have given them the universe their
version of the universe the universe
where moral truth is not objective and
human life is nothing but material it
has no value you've given that to them
you've given them the entire world the
universe reality you've handed
everything to them and now you're trying
to carve out a little chunk here say
yeah you can have the universe but I'm
gonna stand my ground on immigration
why on what basis
you've said that they're correct about
this these two fundamental foundational
things how can you then disagree with
them on on something like immigration
and what is the foundation for your
disagreement take something like gun
rights you can say well yeah they're
right about abortion but don't take my
guns well but hold on a second
you-you-you just agreed that human life
has no real value so why why do you have
a right to a gun the whole reason why
you have the right your right to your
guns is that you need the guns to
protect your life I mean the only a gun
itself has no value on its own
the only value in a gun is that it can
protect preserve and sustain human life
it can sustain it by you know you've got
and hunt and kill animals okay so it has
a value there and it has value because
it can protect human life
but you see that the value of the gun is
hinged on the value of human life if
human life has no value then the gun is
just it's just a toy and it's a
dangerous toy of that and so we should
ban and what if human life has no value
then yeah let's ban all the guns
I mean well because why not why should
you have a gun
why do you have a right to your gun your
life is meaningless
and if somebody wants to kill you then I
mean whatever fine they should kill you
there's no value in your life you're
nothing
you
so you really have to choose
[Music]
what I would say to Tommy and all
conservatives conservatives in her
category is make up your mind
I mean are they wrong or are they right
and forget about them from it but what
about you what do you really believe who
are you what are you what do you
actually believe deep down in your soul
don't tell me about you
shoes don't tell me about Trump okay
don't tell me what it deep down in your
soul what do you believe about life what
are your core principles and values that
that animate and motivate you as a
person
figure out what those actually are
because once you know those you're gonna
see that it's really impossible for you
to stake out this in between ground that
you've tried to find
nobody who's really in touch with their
own values and their own principles
could ever be floating in the middle
there
so figure out who you are and what you
believe
and then take it from there
and if you discover that you know yeah
actually the left I basically agree with
them on most on the most important thing
I'm basically a leftist and that's who I
am and if that's what you discover them
then you know you have every right to it
but be honest with yourself and and be
honest with everybody else
that's my request and that is my
invitation as well
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed